back at University for his final year
life in a working world is becoming very
real for Alex but with a financial
future looking Bleak finding a job which
pays enough is proving difficult a lot
of them just say competitive and it's
hard to get a good grasp on what that
actually means but the ones I do see
they kind of range from kind of 20 to
30k
um which is all right but you know as a
student in the cost of living crisis I'm
really looking to get more than that and
get paid for for what I'm worth
so to build up his finances Alex has a
successful side hustle his adult Lego
blog is already bringing in extra cash
it just kind of supports me and allows
me to do other things like I was able to
go go out on holiday this Summer that
kind of thing which you know as a
student when money's tight I might not
have been able to do that otherwise and
it will just help kind of boost that
income that um yeah unfortunately it's
it's a struggle to find those those good
salaries out there and he isn't alone in
fact research shared with Sky News
suggests students across the country
have high expectations for first-time
salaries and are forced to work extra on
the side
due to the rise in living costs students
now believe they should be earning more
than 30 000 pounds a year when taking up
a graduate job that's 25 more than the
current national average starting salary
plus that looks unlikely around 1810 are
considering taking up a personal side
hustle just to top up their income
like Natasha who brings in an extra ten
thousand pounds a year through her Eco
eyelash business in addition to her
salary from a part-time graduate job
which she feels isn't enough about
balancing this side of well how am I
going to live off that am I going to be
able to move to the location that
they're going to be putting me in what's
my financial situation going to look
like how would I actually be able to to
afford to be living off that wage even
though it is potentially something that
I love doing
these may be demanding expectations but
we are facing demanding times and so
it'll take Innovation and plenty of
hustling from graduates to ride through
this crisis into my machine Sky News
leads